Okay. So, today we're going to discuss
something that might be a bit
controversial. Uh, it might be something
that many people have not heard about
before and it might also be something
that completely makes sense by the end
of this about stuff they've been seeing
all around the world. But we're going to
talk about uh Sunday legislation and how
there is this global push in in in
politics and in the environmental
industries, businesses all over the
world to legislate Sunday observance and
to where we even hear people saying no,
we want to enforce and push the Sunday
law and enforce legislate morality. And
I want to add to this conversation real
quick that even though we are discussing
a certain religious entity or people's
maybe religious opinions, religious um
flavors or or um directions. We are not
attacking individual people who are
sincere who are love Jesus and and who
are part of these religious
institutions. We are not attacking them.
We are just discussing the system and we
are discussing Bible prophecy. But we do
not attack. We respect anybody who has a
different opinion than us and who was
part of this religious entity. So, we're
going to do something a little bit
different today. Um, we've touched on
this here and there, but it might be a
little bit mysterious to some people
yet. We've talked a little bit about the
Antichrist and the mark of the beast.
We've got actually two videos on that
that kind of openly discuss this, but
we've talked about 666. We've talked
about all these interesting cues in
Bible prophecy. But we see the mark of
the beast being fulfilled, being not
like it's out there already, but being
fulfilled, working towards that in
today's society and culture and etc. And
there's evidence for that. Yeah. You
know, it's interesting uh to kind of uh
dig deep into understanding what's
coming. Part of our ministry looks at
what's happened in the past. And you
know, let's take a look at a current
clip here. What happened recently?
Something Trump said that kind of caught
my attention to thinking about what
happened in the past. Through your
leadership, you embody the values of our
Christian faith and love for the gospel.
You remind me of the great Roman Emperor
Constantine the Great.
[Applause]
This emperor,
this emperor, your dear Mr. President,
is the one who founded and built the
magnificent city of Constantinople, my
birthplace.
No.
known today as Istanbul. It is my great
honor to present you with this holy
cross.
Wow. Thank you. This cross is the very
symbol that led this great a Roman
Emperor Constantine to victory. You
know, it kind of goes back to the
Milvian bridge in Hawk Sigo Vincent when
Constantine was facing his enemies and
legend has it he held up this cross uh
or saw had a vision of the cross. Right.
Like there was a cross in the sky.
Right. Right. And it said something like
under this mark you shall gain victory.
Yep. And that's how he became a
Christian afterward. Yeah. In hawk sign.
Uh you know Constantine's interesting
for a couple of reasons too. There was
of course the forgery uh the donation of
Constantine which Rome relied upon
allegedly Constantine giving authority
to the popes to take over and have
authority within the church and
it was discovered by uh Lorenio Valla as
a forgery and then the church tried to
suppress the revelation that it was a
forgery in the index liorum
prohibitorum. So there's a lot of
controversy surrounding Constantine. Uh
it's interesting to me to see more and
more of the conservative Catholics
though pushing for kind of a return if
you will or even referring to Donald
Constantine Trump. You can see this with
St. Michael's media and church militant
referencing Constantine of old. You know
Constantine uh was himself one of the
ones who put forward uh the famous
Sunday law on the venerable day of the
sun. Let the magistrates and people
residing in cities rest and let all
workshops be closed. So you can see and
this is actually a copy of Justinian's
codeex here on the Vatican digital
library containing that law in the
original uh one of one of the original
medieval manuscripts that they have
there. So we can see where Constantine
went uniting church and state on this
subject right here. But it's interesting
to see how these people reflect a
similar push for uniting church and
state and then also bringing about
Sunday legislation as well. This this is
really interesting that you're
mentioning this because yeah, Emperor
Constantine, he was a Roman worshiping
pagan gods and he was used to worshiping
the sun among other things. And so
history tells us that the Christian
church was the biblical Christian church
was keeping Sabbath as the seventh day
of the week and Sunday was actually the
first day of the week which even in the
Bible in the few references in the New
Testament where the first day of the
week is mentioned it's also Sunday. Um
but then Constantine came around and
because of his interaction with like
there was a cross in the sky and said
under this mark you shall gain victory.
They put the crosses on the shields of
the of the soldiers and he held up the
cross and he gained victory and then he
started replacing you know um cathedrals
and different places or sorry I should
say pagan shrines and different places
and just putting Christian crosses on it
became a you know a Christian and then
when the the um there was still this
like hatred for the Jews already back
then the Jews were keeping the Sabbath
but the Christians were also keeping the
Sabbath.
But then because there was hatred for
the Jews, it was hatred for the Sabbath.
So that became less popular to keep the
Sabbath and to appease, you know, the
pagans and the Christians, he's like,
"Oh, well, we'll just have two days of
worship, which is Sabbath and Sunday,
you know, and then eventually Sunday
became more popular and Sabbath got kind
of disappeared off the map, but it was
still in the God's ten commandments in
Exodus 20 with the word remember
attached to it, which was forgotten."
But you know, if we go further here,
this was Michael Voris uh with the
Vortex uh which was a Catholic uh show
on church militant. And you can see long
before Trump getting into power for his
second term, there was a call here for
Trump to kind of be that Constantine and
convert to Catholicism. Mr. President,
you need to become Catholic and you need
to convert now. About four years ago,
Church Milton produced a vortex in the
heat of the 2016 campaign where we
compared Donald Trump to Constantine.
Constantine, of course, was the eventual
sole emperor who defeated Max Centius at
the Battle of the Milvian Bridge just
north of central Rome on October 28th,
312 AD, which happens to be the same
week as this year's election. The
victory paved the way for Christianity
to be freed from the persecutions and
eventually become the religion of the
Roman Empire. Contemporary historical
accounts of the battle note that the
night before the resounding and somewhat
unexpected victory, Constantine received
a vision where he was told if he would
paint the chyros on his soldiers shields
and breastplates, victory would be his.
It's interesting kind of referencing a
sign that you would have victory. And
Michael Voriso has also been calling for
the destruction of religious liberty.
Take a look at this next clip. Why
doesn't God's side have unity? The
answer is because from the very
beginning of the nation, an error was
accepted into the political fabric. the
error that people are free to believe
whatever they want about God and that
somewhere down the road this wasn't
going to present a massive problem in
how the society orders itself. As we
said the snake coiled up under the table
eventually sooner or later it's going to
bite you. I don't like this. I don't
like the fact that the Pope is doing
this. I don't like the fact that there
are Patchchamama idols set up in St.
Peters. All of this to me is
apocalyptic. There, I said it.
This is apocalyptic.
We are seeing religious leaders
team up
with
eco people who are in favor of
infanticide and abortion and
contraception.
Team up with credit card companies.
Team up with social media. Team up with
China. Team up with Joe Biden. Team up
with Hillary Clinton.
All the usual suspects are teaming up.
And what alarms me is Pope Francis is on
that team. So, it's interesting to see
the another conservative traditional
Catholic, Dr. Taylor Marshall talking
about watching the unity between big
business uh the Catholic Church and
government. And you know, he's kind of
questioning like what's going on here.
But the Bible reveals that in the last
days there would be uh you know, a
mother church riding a beast in
Revelation 17. It also reveals that at
the end of time, there would be a beast
power that would seek to control buying
and selling. Mhm. And so for us students
of Bible prophecy, this is no surprise.
But for Catholicism, and many of them
are looking at this and like what's
going on? So ultimately, what are these
guys pushing for? Here's an example of
one of the Christian nationalist
influencers, uh, who stated the
following. The only way to
start the the the the the the return to
to moral order in this country is by
force. It's the only way. It's it's the
only way. It has to be by force at least
for a time.
We have to regulate morality by force.
At least for a time. It's the literally
the only solution. Why? What? Why?
Morals come from the heart, right? It
comes from the mind. It comes the
frontal lobe which is the frontal part
of the brain is the seat of morality.
It's where you make moral decisions for
or against. You can't you can't make
someone do something, force them, and
then say we've changed your morality.
The only thing that the state can can
mandate is outward civil behavior. Like
that's the only thing that they can
actually try and change. They cannot
change the heart. And that's part of the
problem that these individuals are not
recognizing. You know, Sean Foy is
actually on board with the with the
unity of church and state as well. Let's
take a look at some of the statements
he's made and others. That's why we get
called, "Well, you're a Christian
nationalist. You want you want the
kingdom to be the government?" Yes.
You want God to come and overtake the
government? Yes.
You want Christians to be the only ones?
Yes, we do.
We wouldn't be a disciple of Jesus if we
didn't believe that.
We want God to be in control of
everything.
We want believers to be the ones writing
the laws. Yes. Guilty is charged. So, we
did two documentaries about the chosen.
Um, and in both of them, we show how
Jonathan Roomie says, "Yeah, I'm a
Knights Templar." and uh knights
templars are on par with 33rd degree
Freemasons according to the Masonic
structure which is the highest level of
Freemasonry you can achieve Freemasons
uh and I don't want to just throw this
out there just like that but Freemasons
do say in their own writings uh morals
and dogmas by Albert Pike who is a 33rd
degree Freemason he wrote that book and
he says that they worship Lucifer which
is another word for Satan and so um
there's a there's an Instagram post by
Jonathan Roomie where he's hanging at
with him and they they say, "Oh yeah, we
went to this beautiful Templar
inaugurational event and my fellow
Templar brothers and sisters and they're
standing in the picture together." Yeah.
Yeah. You know, there's we had a
governor here recently as well who was
uh an advocate of that. Here's an
example. Many times it's said that one
has to separate
church from state,
but we have an administration that
doesn't believe in that. We have a mayor
who you will hear from shortly
who is definitely one of the chosen. I
can't separate my belief because I'm a
elected official.
When I walk, I walk with God. Now, I I
misspoke there. It's not a governor.
It's a mayor here. Um but case in point,
we're seeing elected officials who are
coming to the conclusion, no, I cannot
separate
uh the two. And so what does that mean
on a practical level? It means
ultimately that we're going to see
individuals impose their beliefs upon
others. Now everybody's familiar with
our current vice president JD Vance.
Back in 2022, he presented at the St.
Franciscan University of Stubenville.
One of the co-presenters at that time
was Dr. Chad Peknel. The uh the
conference was put on by Sorre Amari.
Sarah Amari um used to be the editor uh
he may still be for the Catholic tribune
but in that conference these were some
of the statements put forward and again
this kind of just reckons back to
Constantine for those watching um Dr.
Chad Pecnold said the following. In the
Catholic vision, the sharing of the
common good is precisely the way in
which our personal goods are elevated.
Sabbath laws are a way of publicly
orienting us to God, but also
safeguarding the common good of the
family. So, they're pushing specifically
for Sabbath laws or Sunday laws. And he
goes on to to detail that. But this
isn't something that is just limited to
him. I mean, some people are probably
watching me like, "What are you, you
know, what are you talking about? Is
there is there really that much
discussion going on about Sabbath laws
today?" Yeah. And by Sabbath laws, you
mean, like you said, Sunday, because
that's that's how they see as the
Sabbath, not the biblical Sabbath,
Friday evening till Saturday evening.
They frame it as the quote unquote
Christian Sabbath, but biblically it's
not. But I started screenshotting
actually Sunday law news articles
pushing for it and collected about 500
over the past few years. over 500. We
saw it really spike during co because of
course there was an emergency going on
and a lot of excuse to go and and create
such laws. But let's just take a look at
all of the screenshots of some of those
articles and also what's being talked
about in churches across the United
States. So this is something that's
being widely discussed.
Yeah, we'll make that law. Sabbath blue
laws. Blue laws. A blue law. Blue laws.
Blue laws. Blue laws. Sabbath laws on
Sunday. Maybe the Sabbath laws. Blue
laws. Blue laws. Blue laws. Sunday
closing laws. Blue laws. Blue laws meant
everything was closed. The blue laws.
Blue laws. Blue laws. The blue laws. Be
Sunday Sabbath laws. Blue laws. Blue
laws or Sabbath laws. Sabbath laws.
Sabbath laws. I remember the blue laws.
Stories about the blue laws. When these
laws are known as blue laws. Blue laws.
Blue laws. It used to be this thing like
we would impose that on the entire
culture to remember the blue laws. They
have the blue laws. They were called
blue laws. Sunday blue laws. Everything
has to stay closed on a Sunday. Germany
still has blue laws. So blue laws were
Sunday everything shut down. Blue laws
in America. Of blue laws still makes a
lot of sense. We had blue laws. Remember
the blue laws? Any of you remember
reading about that? At least almost
every state had what was called the blue
laws is everything's closed on Sundays.
They still have blue laws on Sunday, so
everything's closed. The only way to
start the the the the the the return to
to moral order in this country is by
force. It's the only way. We really need
to be really ruthless when it comes to
the exercise of power. Okay. So,
interesting note. Do you know about 1610
and Virginia blue laws? H. So in 1610,
the Virginia colony, the first of the 13
colonies, enacted a blue law that
required mandatory attendance at Sunday
church services. And then here's the
violations that happened. First offense,
so the law mandated that all colonists
attend both morning and afternoon church
services on Sunday. You have to go to
church by law. Uh first offense, if you
don't come, loss of food allowance for
the week. Uh where do we find that in
the Bible? Revelation 13, maybe the mark
of the beast. Second offense, loss of
food allowance and whipping. Third
offense, death. Yeah. I mean, we we
can't say, "Oh, well, there's no way the
United States is not going to do this
when all of this is happening. It's
happened in the past and then we have
1888 where we have another blue law that
almost came in like this, a Sunday law."
So, you remember how Constantine said in
hiko, right? In this sign, you will
conquer. Um, it's interesting to me to
see a sign discussed in the catechism.
So, if you go to 2176, it states, "The
celebration of Sunday observes the
moral, notice it's moral, not
ceremonial, moral commandment inscribed
by nature in the human heart to render
to God an outward visible public and
regular worship as a sign of his
universal beneficence to all." Now, in
the in the catechism here, first off, I
find it's interesting referencing the
sign because in the Bible in Exodus
31:17, God's sign is the 7th day
Sabbath. But if you go to the citation
here for 109 right there, it takes you
back to Thomas Aquinus. Mhm. So, I went
to the Vatican digital library and
grabbed the oldest Thomas Aquinus
manuscript I could find, the Suma
Theologia, Sagunda Secund, the barb.lat
792 here. And he goes on to to state the
following here. Now notice he's talking
about the third precept, not the fourth
because remember Rome deleted the second
commandment and shifted the
commandments. Yeah. The second one
meaning you shall not worship any idols
making grave images. Right. So it states
here now the precepts of the decalogue
are so to speak first and common
principles of the law. And consequently
the third precept of the decalogue
describes the exterior worship of God as
the sign of a universal boon that
concerns all. So he's recognizing the
sign here
and describing Sunday as that external
sign. Well, they also have quotes uh
from the Catholic Church where they say
that this the Sunday them changing
Sabbath to Sunday which they admit to is
the mark of their authority. I mean you
can just look this up. There are so many
quotes where they say we changed Sabbath
to Sunday. Dastomin is a classic example
from Pope John Paul 2 where he talks
about the sacramental monatis which
profoundly marks the church and what's
interesting about this though is that
you know in the Bible in Exodus 13:9 and
Deuteronomy 6-8
God's law was to be a sign and
specifically the Sabbath as well Exodus
31:17
on your forehead and your thoughts and
on your hand okay as frontlets between
your eyes right here. So, if you have an
alternative sign here that's marking
your forehead and your hand. Mhm. I
mean, that's apocalyptic. That's right
out of Revelation uh 13 and 14 right
there. Yeah. And and you know, we have a
whole video that discusses in depth like
what we believe the mark of the beast
is, which I think at this point is
pretty clear what we're referring to.
Yeah. Um and but the the the
scriptures point out that the hand
denotes doing something. It's acts and
the forehead is the thoughts. It's it's
where you it's actually the forehead is
the the seat of morality of worship of
the will. And so if the Bible says in
Revelation 13, you receive the mark in
the forehead or the hand, you know, you
cannot be a believer, a Christian
believer who believes, uh, you know, I'm
I'm worshiping on Sunday, etc. But you
can still act it out as an atheist if if
there's a death penalty, a lot of people
will take it. I mean, look at what
happened in Virginia. And I should say,
we're not saying that right now if you
worship on Sunday, you have the mark of
the beast. Absolutely not. That's not
that that's not what prophecy indicates.
It's when Sunday is enforced fully and
the antichrist power has its power back
fully. That's when it becomes the mark
of the beast. Um but not yet. And God is
gracious to people who aren't aware of
this yet. I mean, I used to worship on
Sunday and I used to be, you know,
non-denominational Christian before I
studied the Bible and discovered the
Sabbath and everything. Um but God says
in his word he winks at our ignorance
and on top of that he judges us
according to um our works but like how
much we know. He judges according to the
light given to us. There's I mean there
was a time when the Catholic Church was
the only church all over the world right
where you know people would worship on
Sunday. They would uh uh worship statues
and all that. They just didn't know. And
God's not going to be like, "Sorry, you
didn't know, but um you're out." Well,
they they were certainly the church
that, you know, that appeared to be the
only one. We know God had his church out
out in the the wilderness, but um it's
interesting to see though how much
discussion is trending this direction
towards uh Sunday legislation. Let's
take a look at some news articles here.
So here's Sorreb Omari writing for
Desireette News where uh restoring the
Sabbath, how desorb Omari wants to mend
our broken thread of tradition. You've
got Bed Bath and Beyond uh starting to
talk about Sunday happier. Now this this
is interesting how these are uh
mentioned in so many different clips.
Piggly Wiggly closing down. You've got
uh mayors demanding lockdowns on
Sundays. Give us back Sunday. I mean,
even in places where you would think,
hey, you know, Malaysia, like isn't that
predominantly like Muslim, um, you've
got Taiwan, maybe Buddhist or something?
I'm I'm not positive for Malaysia, but I
believe primarily Islamic. Uh, but they
want Sunday. Samoa wants to ban Sunday
trading. And you've got Adrien Vermule,
Harvard law professor, of course, re
retweeting all of the stuff from Sarab
Amari and others. And in Germany, of
course, uh, Sunday construction site, if
you were to work there, you would get
fined. During the height of COVID,
individuals were booked in Tamil Nadu
and other places for violating Sunday
lockdown norms. They would violate or
they would lock down just on Sundays and
you couldn't go out and do anything.
Mississippi governor declaring Sunday a
day of prayer and fasting. Now, you
mentioned 1888. Of course, there was the
Blair Act then, but those the sister
organization up in Canada tried to push
through and they did get a federal
Lord's Day act briefly, but now you've
got Quebec and the Canadian Arch Dascese
actually sponsoring this attempt to go
get uh the Canadian National Assembly to
bring back a federal Lord's Day Act in
Canada. Uh, of course, they've got
celebrities involved.
Sicily shutting down, Puerto Rico
shutting down. Uh in Greece, if uh there
was a fine for €3,000 for a butcher who
opened his shop on Sundays.
The Union Springs Herald actually wrote
uh regarding all of the different blue
laws that they are not unconstitutional,
nor are they discriminatory. And this
opens the way for all the presently
confused, contradictory local and state
laws to be replaced by a national law
that will standardize the enforcement of
Sunday blue laws all over America. So
they're calling for this to be kind of
um very widespread. Of course, Fox News
here talking about and asking the
question um this was about one or two
years or maybe two three years ago.
Should all stores close on Sunday to
allow staff a day off to recuperate?
So, in Slovenia,
the National Assembly banned trade on
Sundays and holidays. We're seeing a lot
of support for this. This was an
interesting uh tweet by Donald Trump
here stating, "Happy Sunday, we want
God." And he actually refers back to the
people of Poland, how they defeated
communism by appealing to Pope John Paul
2. John Paul 2 is the one who wrote dasy
talking about Sunday profoundly marking.
So, we can see where Trump's leaning in
terms of referencing Catholic history
here and also honoring Sunday in his
tweets. Break.
All right, I can do this.
[Music]
All right.
There are conventional ways of sharing
the gospel, but some may need a
different way of doing things. Um, never
mind. A way that gets the message out
with confidence.
Wow, cool shirt. What's it mean? Oh,
thank you. You know, we're all made with
a unique fingerprint, but we're all
God's artwork. Wow. Where'd you get it?
Lightwear. Wear your witness.
[Music]
Hi, my name is Alex and I'm policy
advisor at Kissi which is the commission
of the bishop's conference of the
European Union. With the coid9 pandemic,
many people are suffering from poverty
and loneliness. This is why we need
fraternity more than ever. We need to
care for each other for we are all
members of one human family.
This is why at Ks we are committed to
promote Sunday as a common weekly day of
rest in the European Union. A day that
gives time for family and spiritual
life. A day uh to experience social
friendship and fraternity.
I think it sounds good though and I
think that's maybe
you know the deception behind it. And I
think a lot of these people who are
involved are not evil people. M I think
a lot of them are just like, "Yeah, like
I I'm sick and tired of this atheistic
society that we live in where everything
goes. I want God back." And so why don't
we have legislature that allows for
people to not work and they can actually
rest, spend time with family and
worship. And then for for me, you know,
I keep the weekly Sabbath, this this
Friday evening to Saturday evening
Sabbath. I love it. Time for my husband
and I. time to visit with friends and go
hiking in nature and and have a meal
together, go to church. Um, but
I I I the problem is that, you know,
scripturally speaking, the Sunday is not
biblical. And in fact, in in the New
Testament, there's only eight references
to the first day of the week or to
Sunday. And in five of those occasions,
it was the same event. So that leaves
you with a total of what is it four five
occasions where it's all different
occasions. That's it. And the Sabbath is
mentioned over and over and over again
even being kept by the apostles etc. So
I want to be kind to the people who who
are really um um um promoting this
because I think a lot of them are
genuine. It's just this is not what God
designed. And we can see that prophecy
is being fulfilled in this trajectory.
Yeah. You know, it's it's interesting
seeing how this has influenced pop
culture even. You know, here's Kanye
West. Most people are probably familiar
with this song.
On Sunday,
you my Chickfila.
[Music]
They're trying to push it. And you know
this is what happened here recently
actually SESI the European unions and uh
Uni Europa some of the other sponsors
they got together with the European
Sunday Alliance and pushed and sold
their case to members of European
Parliament there's a push to get this
for all of Europe. Mhm. So as kind of
we've expected for a long time for this
to come about in the United States like
they're prepping the groundwork and the
framework for this to go globally very
very quickly. And so you can see the the
push occurring. It was interesting
during COVID too. Part of the Sunday
lockdowns involved uh kind of shutting
down everything. Any kind of commerce on
Sunday you could not do. And it was
really interesting to see what the
streets look like uh on Sundays
specifically. What did that Sunday
lockdown look like?
[Music]
kind of looks like a ghost town. I
remember when um when CO happened and it
was like there was a a call for a
lockdown in in in the area where we live
and it was like one day it was like
quiet as anything but then soon after
you know we're in a republic state it
was like ah everybody's back to normal
um but yeah that's that's that's very
interesting and I remember watching a
nature documentary that came out after
CO and it was talking about how um
during COVID the environment was so much
better which I'm I'm guessing you might
be going into that a little bit I don't
know uh with the Sunday green Sabbaths
and stuff like that that are being
promoted as the same kind of idea behind
this. But this nature documentary was
talking about how uh um because because
of COVID and all the industries were
shut down, nature was so much better,
the environment was better, and
therefore maybe we should have a weekly
day off where we don't do anything and
we just lock down. And I'm I'm pretty
sure that they also suggested Sunday.
Yeah, you know, we're seeing this uh
obviously push for multiple angles.
Environmental is one of them. Um, one of
the big ways though is we're seeing the
conservatives and Christian nationalism
uh start to call for it. And it's not
just the Heritage Foundation with
Project 2025. I know we did a video on
that. Um, but it's also Naccon and in
their statement of principles, they're
calling for it too and they're talking
about it quite a lot in their
conferences. Here's Orin McIntyre. Uh he
has a show a podcast on the blaze and
let's take a look. The individual worker
um rather the individual worker who has
a large family with many children may be
unwilling to devote his entire life to
the corporation. The devout Christian
may oppose commerce on Sabbath or the
practice of usery. Now Patrick Denin uh
who put together America's pre-liberal
past and post-liberal futral uh national
conservatism this was conference two
right here also talking about it. Many
mandated uh uh laws against blasphemy
and required observations of the
Sabbath. I grew up in Connecticut at a
time when there were still things called
blue laws. Believe it or not, these
kinds of mandates on behalf of the
common good were common, frequent, and a
deep and inherent part of the American
tradition. So, they're referencing this
as something that was very much in our
past, as you mentioned, back in like
1610 and and other other time periods in
American history. And there's a call to
kind of return back to that. Kevin
Roberts with the Heritage Foundation
also talked about this pledge that
Naton's pushing for. Called for quote
restoring to our nation a proper public
orientation toward the virtues of
patriotism and courage, honor and
loyalty, religion and wisdom,
congregation and family, man and woman,
the Sabbath and the sacred, and reason
and justice. Yeah. So he's behind
pressure 2025 which like you said we
have a video on as well. Yes. Uh here is
the Sorre Omari. This is the guy who put
on the conference that JD Vance went and
spoke at back in 2022 restoring the
nation that that they should that they
should be keeping the Sabbath in in some
significant way. Now you you just um
published uh uh an an essay in the Wall
Street Journal, I guess an excerpt. Uh
what is your message of the Sabbath? I
guess I would argue for re restoring
Sabbath blue lots. So he Yeah. Now one
of the big individuals and actually I've
reached out to him to try and and bring
him on to some of the shows and channels
out there uh maybe to come have some
dialogue with us but so far haven't
gotten an acceptance yet is Steven Wolf.
uh Steven Wolf has been making the
rounds and wrote the book the case for
the Christian nationalism like writing
writing in favor of Christian
nationalism and part of the elements
that he's pushing for is blasphemy laws
but also Sabbath laws and he's making a
very wide push currently in Christian
nationalism. What what is blasphemy
laws? Well, if you are condemned
speaking blasphemies uh you know taking
God's name in vain or or other uh you
know outward uh offensive language that
you could be prosecuted for that. So
let's take a look here. One of them is
civil law and the other one is social
customs. So civil law is is just
something that the that we're we're
basically um com ordered to do by the
magistrate
uh for our good. Uh and so this
everything from you know speed limits uh
and I think also Sabbath laws
uh and then then and we can I mean we
can get into more on that. We're going
to have to because you just took people
they were with you with speed limits but
they lost you on Sabbath laws but we'll
come back. That's all right. Sabbath
laws. I mean, we haven't got to teaser.
We haven't got to blasphemy yet.
Blasphemy law. You uh you do what you
can so that they can worship God and
worship God uh and uh the church can
administer word and sacrament. Uh how in
particular, how would you do that? You'd
have Sabbath laws. And Sabbath laws are
not to simply to punish violations of
fourth commandment, but they're provide
the but to provide the conditions in
which people can worship God without
distraction. So he's not the only one.
One of the other ones from uh Naccon is
actually an attorney, Teimone Klein. So
Teimone Klein sat down with Jared
Longshore. They're actually pushing for
this as well. And then you also want to
make it easy um for Christians to do
Christian things. I mean, that's the
main rationale given by courts for
Sabbath laws. It is in our tradition. It
is historical. Um, but the main thing is
we don't want Christians economically on
Sundays to to be overcome by
non-Christians just because they want to
worship the Lord, right? That's not a
choice they should have to make. We want
to make it very easy for uh and make
every make it um clear to everyone which
Sabbath we're we're in favor of. That's
the religion we want to be perpetuated.
Um so that's just all over the place.
Now, did you catch what he said there?
Which Sabbath? So what is that
referencing there? like are are they
going to ultimately get restrictive
enough to the point where
let's say you're keeping another Sabbath
holy, maybe a biblical one compared to
what the state imposes, that's not going
to be acceptable. I think that there's
there's there's not much wrong with the
first step of this of like, oh, we're
just legislating to make sure that
people don't open on Sabbath. I mean, I
grew up in the Netherlands where in the
beginning I we couldn't shop on Sabbath
and sorry, on Sunday and I was like,
"Yeah, whatever. Doesn't matter." But
it's where it progresses and where it's
headed towards as we know in Bible
prophecy and as they're talking about
some of these individuals are saying,
"Yeah, like we want to legislate
morality and we're going to do it by
force." Yeah. And and we see in Virginia
in 19 1610 that this happened. We see it
in 1888 where they wanted to start
creating these these these Sunday laws
and where you have to worship on Sunday.
And we see it with Constantine that that
he is like, "Yep, we're going to do this
on a Sunday." And uh you know, and and
and Christians who were keeping Sabbath
were persecuted, including the Waldenzes
who were faithful Christians in that
time during the dark ages and and and
before the dark ages even and and they
were persecuted. So, we know from Bible
prophecy that this is how it's going to
end up. And Ecclesiastes says history
repeats itself. Well, you you know, of
course, whether or not this is a good
idea to even step one foot down this
road, that's a you know, that's a that's
a good question to ask because, you
know, as it stands right now, if you
want to take another day off, uh if you
need to take a day off, there is already
uh laws in place that protect against
religious discrimination. So what we
don't need to have is we don't need to
have a law that comes along and mandates
that every business be closed because
think about it from this perspective. If
you're a Christian that believes that
you ought to rest on the seventh day,
the commandment also states that to work
six days. So you have a biblical duty to
work the rest of the of the of those six
days as well. Now, does that mean we're
going to go around and give offense to
our neighbor and openly try and manifest
a anarchy rebellious spirit by
exercising our religious liberty to give
offense? No, that's not the case. Uh
even in the case of the Waldenes back in
their day, they actually uh worked on
Sunday violating the law, but did so
privately to to avoid giving offense. So
there's a problem with the laws even
though they are well-meaning even from
the very outset there's other ways to go
about it apart from saying okay we're
just going to lock down because that's
the first step I would towards that
direction and you know Jared Longshore
some of these uh fellows are going uh
and making it very clear which direction
they want to go and it's not so innocent
if our civil rights come from the triune
God does it not follow that civil
allegiance must be paid to him we might
stamp in God we trust on our money we
might declare that we are one nation
under God. We might structure our civil
affairs such that on the one day in
seven which God has deemed holy, we rest
from our work and worship him. This
civil and public acknowledgement should
certainly be formalized in our governing
documents. How could we do any other if
our rights come from him? But it is not
going to stop there. If our rights come
from God, then won't it follow that our
laws must come from him? It would be
quite strange if our rights came from
God, but then the law of our land paid
no regard to what he has revealed. I
dare say that the God-given rights might
collide with the laws of our land if
those laws went rogue and didn't pay
attention to the rights giver. Moreover,
if our rights come from the triune God,
then does that not mean that we would
need leaders from him as well? So, he's
he's not stopping. Uh they're they're
planning on taking this all the way in
terms of uniting church and state. And
yeah, it sounds like a theocracy.
Exactly. And they get a little bit more
uh explicit to that point. This is an
example of Joel Webb, another one who I
have reached out to personally to try
and invite uh but he was too busy adopt
a distinctly pre uh Christian preamble
and then all all the ten commandments
must be legislated. what what we've done
is we thought the second table of the
law so second table meaning commandments
5-10 uh the commandments of God that
pertain to our horizontal relationship
with our neighbor like don't steal don't
murder these kinds of things we think
that should be legislated by the civil
magistrate but the first table of law
not that um but that's not true and I'm
not just talking about old covenant
Israel in the old testament you look at
king Alfred you look at Constantine uh
you look at Richard the Lionhe heart you
look at Duke Godfrey who who chopped a
uh a Turk uh in half diagonally with one
swing of the sword. These guys, they
legislated both tables of the law.
That's where all the prosperity comes
from. Uh because you can't hang in
midair uh these second table
commandments of don't steal from your
neighbor apart from uh have no other
gods before me. Idolatry is the head,
the fountain head of the stream. You
cannot have an idolatrous people and yet
somehow have a moral people. And this
goes back to the, you know, the question
of the covenants in Israel's day, uh,
and ultimately the new covenant. The one
who writes the law on our hearts. It's
in Hebrews. Exactly. That's the new
covenant. Hebrews 8 to go, uh, and write
the law on our hearts. That's the job of
the Holy Spirit. Mhm. Yeah. That that is
not the job of government because
government can only affect maybe outward
civil behavior. And even that is is
poorly done. the uh the only one who can
change the heart and actually eradicate
idolatry is the Holy Spirit. That's
right. And that's that's where God
changes our morality on the inside and
not it's just acts. Um and you know,
thinking about the old new covenant,
there's many people who say, "Well, I'm
a new covenant Christian and therefore I
don't keep the old covenant." But if you
really study the covenants, it isn't
like, "Oh, the Old Testament has been
done away with or the law has been done
away with." with I mean we we've done a
couple of videos on that just showing
that God's law is still valid today.
There's that I I I've heard pastors
saying and I agree with this. I will
give you a million dollars if you can
show me from the Bible that the Sabbath
was changed to Sunday. You can there's
not one verse that indicates that. But
you know like you said the new covenant
was just to affirm reaffirm the old
covenant and the new covenant Hebrews is
just reaffirming God now writing his
laws in our hearts and our minds. He
wants us to have that relationship with
him. If you think about it too, if
you've got a whole nation that's obeying
for fear of coercion or for fear of
punishment, yeah, what you've just done
is mandated and inscribed in law a vast
amount of hypocrisy for individuals who
are obeying for fear uh as the
motivation instead of love. Yep. And so
they're not actually obeying at that
point. You've just created a whole bunch
of hypocrites who on the outward look
like they're law-abiding Christians, but
on the inward are ravening wolves. Yeah.
And I mean I mean God wants that
relationship like I said and he wants to
have the heart, a renew of the heart, a
sanctified heart, which the Bible even
refers to the Bible as as uh the thing
that sanctifies that God uses for us to
sanctify us. Um he doesn't want robots.
And if he did, he would never have given
Adam and Eve the ability to even sin. He
would have just been like, "No, you're
just a bunch of robots that worship me."
He doesn't want that, right? And Joel
Webbon, you know, here's where he's
going with this. First table laws being
legislated by uh by a Christian
government in a nation. Uh that would be
examples like blue laws, uh being uh
Sabbath laws, which we've had in America
in our history. And you still have
hangover blue laws on the books in
places like where I am in Texas. Like
liquor stores, New York City even has
them. There you go. Yeah. Like liquor
stores in Texas don't open on on the
Lord's Day until I think it's noon or
something. It's it's basically after
church. I'm in a smaller town,
Georgetown. Um and there's a lot of
restaurants that don't open until noon.
Um because the morning and and every
other day of the week, it's not like
they just do that, you know, 7 days a
week. It's distinctly on the Lord's day
because in the morning you go to church.
Um and so so blue laws is that's not a
crazy thing. It's not like some
hypothetical that's never taken place.
It's funny that he talks about the
liquor stores opening after church. So
it's like that's the question of
morality, right? Like I'll go to church
by force cuz it's forced, but then
afterward I'll go to the liquor store
and drink myself drunk. That doesn't
make sense. Well, think about it like
this. You know, in James 2:10, if a man
breaks one commandment, he's broken the
whole law, right? So, if you are going
and out and getting drunk later on,
you're I mean, you're not keeping any of
God's commandments. If you're going and
breaking one of them, you're breaking
all of them. Uh it's interesting that
even Jordan Peterson has gotten in on
this discussion recently. It's shifted
to Sunday because Christ is seen as the
new creation. Right. So fine. Are you
It's okay. Are you bound is a Christian
bound to Sunday? Well, I would say it
depends. I would say yes. But Dennis,
remember the difference between reality
and ritual is in the Hebrew scriptures,
too? I wonder if Jordan realized right
at the critical moment when he was going
to ask that question, he got cut off.
Hm. Could be. Yeah. I mean, it was it
was very interesting kind of what
happened there. And I don't know if he
realized that. Um Yeah. He's quite the
critical thinker, which I think is good.
Yeah. Uh you know, take a look though
here, we've talked about the exemption
clause in Project 2025. Uh one of the
things that I find interesting though is
that um the discussion on blue laws. If
you kind of go back to uh the 19th
century, you know, we've talked about uh
perhaps previously some of the
legislation that's taking place in
Oklahoma and Louisiana, but there was a
individual by the name of Alonzo Jones
who was actually responding to Philip
Shaft. There's a probably a lot of
Protestants out there who might have
heard of Philip Shaft as as a famous
Protestant 19th century historian. And
there were three ways in which he
believed that the church could unite
with the state or the state could unite
with the church. Marriage, Sunday laws,
and public education. So when we're
seeing uh some of the legislation coming
through in Louisiana and elsewhere
mandating the ten commandments in the
public school system, there are two
other links in which they believed
classically that the church could unite
with the state. His argument was a
history which would ignore God, Christ,
the Bible, the church, the reformation,
and the faith of the first settlers of
this country would be nothing but a
ghastly skeleton of dry bones. Now,
Alonzo Jones responded. He said, "The
state cannot teach Christian religion or
Christian morality because, as we showed
in the April Sentinel, it has not the
credentials for it. It is with the
church that Christ promised to be till
the end of the world. Without the
presence and help of the Holy Spirit, no
religious teaching can ever be
effectual. Amen. And you know, take a
look. I I have a case uh example of
that. Look at Louisiana's hypocrisy
here. They're talking about legislating
the ten commandments. And what did they
do? They truncated the ten commandments,
specifically the fourth commandment.
remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. But all the rest of the definition
that even mentions the name of God and
his status as creator of heaven and
earth that gives authority to the entire
law was deleted and removed. And the
fact that we're keeping the seventh day,
which is also in the following verses
that it doesn't say anything here. For
all the talk of some of these previous
uh videos of individuals talking about,
we want to make it very clear which
Sabbath we're keeping. The law here in
Louisiana cut out the very definition of
which Sabbath the law of God was told us
to keep. Yep. So, it's interesting. And
here's the American Sentinel here where
Alonzo Jones responded, "The state
cannot teach the Christian religion or
Christian morality because as we showed
it has not the credentials for it. That
work is committed to the church alone."
He goes on, "Without the presence and
help of the Holy Spirit, no religious
teaching can ever be effectual. But it
is the church which is an inhabitation
of God through the spirit. None of these
things are spoken to the state nor of
the state. None of these things pertain
to the state. But without these things,
no effectual religious instruction can
ever be a possible. Therefore, it is
perfectly certain the state never can
with any propriety whatever take upon
itself to give religious instruction.
It's fascinating. But yet when churches
are devoid of the Holy Spirit, when they
are weak because they have not the
spirit of God because they've rejected
that spirit, Mhm. they turn as false
religions do to the power of the state.
And it's interesting too, where are we
seeing pushes for, you mentioned the
climate aspect. We'll close on this
video here, uh, as far as where that's
coming from. The 2024 G7 summit in Italy
promises to be a pivotal event in
shaping a more sustainable future for
our planet. As the world's leading
economies gather, the agenda will focus
on critical issues such as economic
resilience, security, and ethical AI
development. The esteemed participation
of Pope Francis will lend a moral voice
to discussions on ethical AI development
and global cooperation.
Italy's diplomatic efforts will advocate
for a ceasefire in Gaza and a reduction
of tensions in the Middle East conflict.
Italy is pushing for an ambitious coal
phase out by 2025, demonstrating its
commitment to sustainable energy and
environmental stewardship. The Italian
presidency will prioritize the defense
of the rules-based international system
and engagement with developing nations
and emerging economies. The summit's
agenda will cover critical topics like
stability in the Indo-Pacific region,
cyber security, and the responsible
development of artificial intelligence.
One of the most significant proposals
should be the introduction of a weekly
Earth Sabbath to combat climate change
and promote environmental stewardship.
The weekly Earth Sabbath aims to
establish a global day of rest and
reflection on environmental
sustainability, raising awareness, and
inspiring collective action.
By championing the weekly Earth Sabbath,
Italy would position itself as a leader
in international diplomacy and
environmental sustainability on the
global stage.
The 2024 G7 summit and the weekly Earth
Sabbath proposal could present a unique
opportunity to address pressing global
challenges and foster international
cooperation.
We're seeing this push now in the United
States and globally as well. And so, you
know, it's it's it's very interesting. I
have this book here called The Great
Controversy.
And uh we've talked about this book
before. Mhm. But it's it talks about the
events taking place that we've seen so
far. And we've expected this for a very
long time. I remember as a kid actually
first hearing about this probably, I
don't know, 25 years ago. And all of
these events long before they've taken
place, we've expected for a very long
time cuz it's in the Bible. Exactly. And
it's it's interesting to see it unfold.
If you haven't read this book yet or
seen it, it's a fascinating book. I
recommend it highly. Yeah. We'll put a
link in the description to get a free
copy. Um you can just you can get a
physical copy or you can read it online.
But uh yeah, and and also, you know,
again, some people might have heard this
for the very first time. Like, what are
you guys talking about? Like, I'm
hearing about all the Sunday stuff and
wow, this is crazy, but where can I find
this in the Bible? Well, we have a video
on that on our channel um about what the
mark of the beast is. But before you
watch that one, I encourage people at
home to watch the one on who the
Antichrist power is, cuz that's kind of
a predecessor video to the one on the
mark of the beast. So, watch the video,
who is the Antichrist? Then watch the
video. Links are in description for what
is the mark of the beast and then we
have a whole bunch of other resources in
there as well. You did a couple videos
with us before about um how the Sabbath
has actually been kept throughout
history. You've got biblical and
historical uh evidence for that. You've
got two videos on that. Um um there's
tons of resources that we're going to
drop in the comments below or in the
description below. Yeah, make sure to
check it out and check out James'
channel at Biblical Hope and at Heritage
and Hope Ministries where he do regular
updates like this. Yeah. If you like
this video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comments
below and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]